and we are live and welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel and I'm
here with my mom say hello sir hello how
are you doing Jay it's
thank you for advice me back for the
latest discussions on uh some
interesting ideas for Star Trek Picard
season three the finale is coming along
and um you're certainly a person who has
a lot of news and potential ideas and we
want to share some of those ideas
tonight don't we it's going to be
exciting we've got the last two episodes
dropping and I think we can it's going
to be exciting so let's do the intro and
we'll crack on
[Music]
all right
that music ends a bit too quick and I
forget my my man to have another go okay
now awesome
yeah I'm gonna die about with it
I I could probably do it if I wasn't
such an idiot right guys so yeah we are
going to be talking Star Trek this
evening we are going to be talking about
Picard season three the
very surprising exciting pecan season
three
um
I genuinely can't believe it's been this
good and just just really quickly
how much have you enjoyed Picard season
three
um I would say I will very very
um Faithfully say that this is the best
Starship I've seen in nearly 20 years
since the end of um
an Enterprise personally I just feel
that for what we've seen in just these
first Eight Episodes have gone
so dealt so much into the law the
continuity of the Star Trek universe but
particularly the 24th century 25th and
it's ticked all the boxes for me so yeah
it's huge it's fantastic I've adored it
I've admit I can't I'm I'm with you I
think strange new worlds is great and
I've really enjoyed Strange New World I
like that too I love Prodigy I think
Prodigy is great I love lower decks but
this is the best live action Star Trek
distant strange new worlds are they're
close but yeah yeah very very high very
high standards brilliant yeah after the
total [__] show of season one and two of
the card it's a joy to be honest
and um and I actually said if Picard
season three lets me down like Picard
season one or two did I would walk away
from Star Trek I think that'll be me
done and I'm very glad to say
I don't have to walk away from Star Trek
because it's been hanging around you can
you could come back
um I think it's a very strange thing
because
um you know after such an uneven start
with a discovery show which has its fans
fair enough
um it's not quite worked for me but it
it's obviously
um appeal to uh some demographics
um and it's kind of like
um for me
it's it was given the confidence back in
Star Trek after some of the
misdirections after it came back on CBS
Paramount and it's now that they're
steering clear with strange new worlds
and then of course Picard had a very
rough beginning I actually didn't mind
the beginning and the ends of Picard
season two because Terry metallis was
involved with that as well yeah but
season three was a whole different
Dynamic and I I have so many ideas as to
how this show is going to end and this
is what we want to talk about yeah if
season two had been four episodes I
think it would have been all right
absolutely
make the ball completely useless in the
end but that's it we could do an old
episode just talking about girati's book
and now it didn't make any sense but
anyway yeah I will I will just mention
really quickly I do think there's been a
few mistakes in Picard season three
there's a few things that don't make
sense
um or they're so minor compared to
Picard season one or two I don't care
and we're going to talk about the fleet
coming together at the end of this
season that's the whole point the entire
your staff that the entire Frontier day
Frontier Days the frontier day is coming
to Earth
and we'll talk about how that makes no
sense because
it takes six months to cross the
Federation so for like a year
the edges of the Federation are going to
have no defenses at all because but but
that's a thing that Star Trek always
does
the you know June June Star Trek first
Contact the Borger attacking the Earth
the attack starts the Enterprise E is
out right by the Romulan border
um as far away from somebody gets back
and it's suddenly back in two minutes
and it's there yeah it just goes let's
go back into there and and just slap
back in the middle of the floor so
that's a that's a thing that they ignore
in Star Trek all the bloody time but
anyway yeah
final villain for Picard season three we
don't know actually who it is we thought
it was the changelings but now the
strike has been destroyed Captain vidic
who's my favorite villain in Star Trek
for ages she's great
um is dead so we don't actually know
who's pulling the strings but we know
pizza face the guy that wants to cut
around off and talked to her
um isn't a changeling because he kept
talking about your species and your
thing and you you're not as advanced as
you think you are and all this nonsense
all right so
who is the main villain now I think it's
the Borg
thoughts
I I've looked at lots of um discussions
about it with people and there are lots
of uh directions pointed towards the
Borg
um you know it's like come back to us
we've heard we've actually heard Dr
crush's voice in some of these Visions
which is slightly uh misleading but
maybe
um there is something to do with some
subconscious connection to a collective
and he's hearing the collector through
his own Mother's voids it's not it's
it's very unclear but
um it does seem very likely to be the
Borg personally because there's been a
lot of links back to locutus it's been
mentioned a lot
um I think there's been one or two
little awkward I said the first episode
there's this bit where
um he gets that card gets that Trump
that coded message from Beverly and it's
the first thing she says is don't trust
anybody so the first thing he does is
run to Riker
that's right um and he says I watched
this bit I can't remember the word she
uses but what's this thing and like I
said oh you wouldn't know about that you
were incapacitated and it was something
to do with the Battle of all three five
nine we got this virus and it messed
with our navigation that's right yeah
that's right yeah I always said that
didn't make any sense because one Picard
would have read the reports afterwards
and if something had messed with the
navigation systems it would have been in
a report somewhere but anyway we'll
ignore that bit
um but I always thought that was just an
opportunity for him to mention the
cutest because he says incapacitated oh
lakutis yes I can count a million times
you're incapacitated John Luke um there
was that probe thing that made you live
an entire lifetime on another planet
there was that time that the Frankie
came and you got the headache you know
like listing them off and the TNG one
you were incapacitated a lot a lot yeah
yeah absolutely but it was an excuse to
mention the cutest I thought
um so
for me and there's this thing is that
he's got that um disease um that that um
syndrome you're a modest syndrome that
he's got and now they've said well okay
that's not neuromotic syndrome so is
that a leftover from
when he was locutus when he was
assimilated
yeah it's an interesting one I mean um I
should say there has been a lot of
callbacks to the Next Generation this is
one thing which is um uh always been
very good in season three and of course
uh two two of the biggest things which
have been focused on is um again because
Picard technically died of neuromatic
syndrome and of course him being the
cutest a book it was one of the the
biggest things
um so I I do think there is potentially
some uh links because it's brought up
but of course it has been brought up a
lot in previous Seasons as well and of
course I still wonder whether that's
potentially it might be a mislead but it
just seems to me that because of the
history and also you know I've wondered
whether you know if Jack
um technically was conceived which
sounds a bit bizarre after
Picard was returned from the cutest
whether there's something in his DNA
that could have been transferred to Jack
or something there's something but then
they've been after Jack rather than
Picard so that's that's confusing they
only started looking for Jack when they
realized they got Picard's body
yeah I'm from daystrom
yeah they're actually right yeah they
had the body already and then they
started looking for Jack it's like they
got Picard's body expecting to be able
to do whatever it is they're going to do
with Picard's body yeah and then they
were like it doesn't work for whatever
reason
and so they've gone yet we're gonna have
to go and so then they started looking
for Jack that's a good point I think if
they'd have needed Jack before they'd
have captured him weeks before
you know so you're saying is that
because they captured Picard's body and
they realized that something that they
need is in his offspring that's when
they went out to Jack is that what
you're suggesting okay or they they need
his DNA for something I mean they've
suggested they need his DNA because
they're trying to do a replicant of
Picard and I'm like that's a red herring
that's an obvious red herring we know
that doesn't make sense but Terry
matalis who's written the series does
like to thank us one way and then switch
it suddenly yes
brilliant writing I I also don't like
how he doesn't drag things out like like
the Jax Picard Sons didn't drag that out
I'm just there yeah that was very a very
shocking sort of like moment wasn't it
yeah um but it was done really well
um there's a couple of other reasons why
I think it's got to be the Borg
babic which in the last episode when she
was bored
um they were on the bridge and Jack
comes in
vatic actually says to seven of nine
it's very good it's great that you're
here sort of thing it's there's you know
it's it's a really opportunity and you
know it's it's logical that you'll hear
sort of thing
um and she sort of says oh she says that
directly to Seven of Nine so I'm like
well the only thing I can think of that
is that why vatic is so happy she's
there and then it's like ironic or
something that she's there is because
Stefan was Borg yeah so there's that
link I mean I can't imagine what else it
could be that why vatic singled out
seven to say that I mean there was
always the Voyager Trope of every
episode that's a problem and seven of
nine always fix the situation with their
Nano probes it's a very prevalent thing
in that would wouldn't Picard have also
had Nano probes even after he was the
cutest wouldn't that be left over and we
know that they were left over because in
first Contact Picard could hear the Borg
you could hear The Whispers so there
must have been something left over and
that
I I think they've made a little bit of
mistake you know they're saying that
Jack is now sidekick and I think they're
gonna point to that Picard could hear
the voices when he was the Borg so they
I think they might say that it's kind of
the same thing
but I would say well no that's not he's
he's hearing the collective he's hearing
the Subspace signal
um that does not make sense then why
Jack is now suddenly sidekick
um but I I do wonder if that's where
they're going with that and I think the
red door is literally just some sort of
psychological
thing that's like blocking
locutus basically
and when they're going to be like a
defense you mean it's like a defensive
barrier yeah he's being he's got the
compulsion maybe from the Borg or
whatever it is to actually open the door
to reconnect in some way
I'm going to help you through and I'm
like no don't you stupid woman don't
don't do this
leave the door shut if anything you know
from psychology if somebody's got a big
red door and they I've suddenly got
psychic abilities leave the [__] door
shut
um I'm just saying just leave it until
after you know yeah
you know the threat's gone leave it
alone yeah like don't play with fire
yeah exactly yeah
um another thing that I was interested
though is though is
what was locutus right because Shaw made
the point and it was episode five when
he's having a go at Picard and he said
the cutest was so bad they named him and
I think that was really prevalent
because obviously Borg didn't have names
they didn't have you know they had
numbers
the queens were queens and we know we
think there was more than one of them
but I mean although the same being but
replicated
unique within the Borg
well the thing is I mean seven also had
a similar premise because she was a a
communication conduit for Voyager I know
it's not the same thing but there was
some parallels That lacutus was supposed
to be the representative of the Borg
communicating with invasion of
starfleets he was like an icon like a
figurehead he wasn't a bald queen or a
ball King but he had something different
from the normal Borg which made him
difference yeah but I do agree with that
but I still think that didn't seven have
a similarity in some ways that she was
also a representative she didn't have a
designation did she she was so she
wasn't considered special enough to name
her thing different about the cutest or
special that he actually got a name now
I'm wondering
is locutus
actually is locutus just Picard Borg or
his locutus something else that was then
Blended sort of with Picard because then
Picard led the attack he wasn't just a
figurehead he was leading the attack in
Wolf 359 and the battle
um with the enterprise we see Captain
Picard
with the big screen basically
controlling everything
there was a great scene in The Best of
Both Worlds where Guyana was talking to
Riker about the fact that they can't
defeat they've got to defeat Picard yeah
not just not just because they're Borg
now was partly Picard because as you say
a lot it wasn't just like assimilation
it was more than that as you say his
Essence was a much stronger aspect of
the Borg because of his experiences so
there could be some
um agreement in what you're saying that
there was a difference and that
difference maybe is something which is
coming back to where we are now I see
where you're coming from
um just as an interesting sidebar we'll
come back to locutus in one second but
Kevin's main entry point and just
reminded me of something
there's a theory that
um the Borg are actually a threat to the
queue and a Continuum
um and that they because they look for
Perfection so they would see something
like the queue and even though the Borg
might not be a threat to the queue now
they might be at some point in the
future
and there was a theory actually that the
Federation was introduced to the Borg to
create a proxy war
so that we would actually defeat the
Borg or weaken the Borg for them
um so maybe maybe Q is going to jump
into this at some point I mean q and I
mean obviously Q introduced the ball to
the Federation in the first place so and
we know
um that the queue died out what if there
was something I mean the queue died in
season two
excuse me it wasn't actually explained
properly
what killed him we just knew that he was
dying yeah it wasn't interesting if
there was somehow it might be yeah but
they're supposed to be immortal Q's is
supposed to be immortal like it
shouldn't be getting old he should be
omnipotent and going on forever so and
this is a this is a plot hole or a bad
plot in season two why did Q die he
didn't what's it explained wouldn't it
be interesting there was some link to
that in season three with the book maybe
something a link to the board maybe yeah
um let's go back to the cutest stuff I I
do wonder where the locutus we've seen
the queen
pork
that's never really explained what a
queen is why it's different
um but maybe locutus is some sort of
male version or equivalent maybe locutus
is you know because obviously the Borg
are lots of species brought together
they were individuals at some point
maybe I'm wondering whether it's
something deep and dark in the Borg's
past that there's this being this
locutus and that he's still there and
that that was what was merged with
Picard
and what we're going to see is the main
villain now is this locutus which is a
bit of Packard a bit of whatever that
other being was
um and it's the cutest good point
because you think about Queens in the
past when a queen dies you get another
queen and sometimes they look exactly
the same sometimes they look slightly
different what if as you say it is the
cutest
um and Picard is going to face his
Nemesis his demons in in the last two
episodes and this is the threats uh yeah
that could be that could be really
interesting
that Diana does say it's a dark and
ancient entity so maybe it is an ancient
Borg entity that exists within the
collective that you know like a queen
but
different that we've not seen before you
know
um
we know the Borg have been around for
thousands of years so I should say it's
been ancient threat and it slowly
evolved and increased as as the
centuries have gone by through a
simulation of more and more cultures
um yeah I could see that
if if they're doing what we think
they're doing for the last two episodes
they really have got to bring
back the Borg I think I I think it's
like I think it's very likely it's the
book I don't know how do you think it
could necessarily be there but I
actually think it could be just locutus
I think it could actually be
specifically locutus that's coming back
the ball going though is still
relatively weakened after the battles
with um 8472 and Voyager spanking their
ass as well but it has been about 30
years since Voyager in this timeline
um so you know they and we know they
assume they they can repair themselves
quickly
but I'm wondering is it the cutest
attack for Revenge maybe and not
necessarily the Borg as a collective
an individual ball who's been separated
from the collective but as the
knowledgeable accuses yeah I can see
where you're coming from yeah
it doesn't explain all of Jack's
abilities but nothing does
no to be honest
um so we'll have to say unless I was
gonna say unless this is all uh
hey Donny how you doing sir I've not
seen you before so hello I thought I'd
say looks I don't recognize the name
um
if changing this could imitate to decent
sausage I'd eat one
belly I don't
know
like that's amused me sorry Cumberland
sausage yeah good yeah yeah boy chains
long sausage lovely
um
but if it's not the Borg there's there
have been a couple of other ideas
knocking about and they want one being
the power wraith yeah
um from Deep Space Nine so if you don't
remember it was the end of Deep Space
Nine we had the um the celestial beams
that were in the
um
bloody Wormhole thank you
um the prophets and they had an evil
version the pie race that were trapped
on um Asia and that got released towards
the end of
um that by um golden cup
so
there was one theory that this is the
power wraith
um I've I've never quite understood that
theory though because why would the par
Wraith
be so determined to defeat oh well I
mean they say they're going to destroy
the Federation which we'll talk about
what we think that means in a minute but
I'm not sure why the power wraith would
be that interested
I'm trying to think about how the pile
right interacted on DS9 with the
Federation they were from what I
remember they were more an antagonist
for the actual the prophets themselves
they're more interested in destroying
the profits rather than
um
humans and and biological you know I
mean it's slightly different things if
they've got hold of Cisco that one might
be different they might have like wanted
to give Cisco a bit of a slap but I've
said no I never quite made that
connection but it would just be like Joe
matalis to do that and just throw that
completely from left wing and just go
what
um the other thing is though I think
though why I genuinely think it's a
board because everything's been set up
for the Borg I think there's a little
bit of a thing that the Borger kind of
ruined at the end of season two of
Picard and they weren't used well they
were supposed to be that was the big
Return of the of the biggest villain
from Star Trek and it was a bit of a wet
lettuce
might be thinking you know what if I'm
doing a TNG series how do you not have
the Borg in it
that's what I think that's what I think
because I mean I remember the Borg in
the first season where they had this
huge ball Cube and this is one scene
where the ball girl is suddenly going to
be activating on the ship and then
several of line of someone just flushes
out the airlock and all the all the
drones just get flashed out and I
remember saying no I want to see proper
Borg I want to see them going along and
you know
none of them just held on to something
space and I was I was so disappointed
about that and then season two we had
the the that storyline um which really
didn't sort of like do them much just
either and I just want to see like the
Borg from like first Contact the proper
Borg with the proper mate it actually
looked like the Borg and they act like
the Borg and everyone's terrified about
them and they're so powerful and you
know wouldn't it be great it's the last
episode with
um Federation day or Frontier day that
you had like a fleet of bork Ships
coming in I don't think you're gonna get
all that but I would love to see all
that person because
because that was one of the things we
were going to talk about sorry yes yeah
do you think there's anything else
and any other threats um there's been
there's been people I mean the
the aliens from season one of the Next
Generation with the little bluegills uh
most people
were shot in Flames but it I know that
Terry mattalis has been asked and he did
consider using them at one point for
season three because there are some
parallels with what they did and where
we are in some ways it's a chains and
they're taking over key elements I think
yeah exactly which we're doing in season
one of the TNG
um other people are saying it's really
random things like armas the the oil
slick that killed Tasha yeah I don't
think that's gonna happen
um that's the two I've heard about he's
got a lot Power more powerful if that's
him conspiracy episode it's my favorite
episode from the first series of TNG I
think the first series of TNG was very
Jean Roddenberry and then this one
episode just stuck out I was like bloody
that was good upstairs but the thing I
liked most about that was um you've got
the guy sat in the chair and Picard and
Riker come in and you know they're all
very much um you know like alter new
species and we should communicate and
think not that time they walked in that
thing and they just went oh I don't like
it killed that was it
he went like
that yeah that was it yeah
also basically one thing we come in
please shoot to kill shoot together yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah start checking for
1987 yeah very often it's like that was
the one very few occasions so like yeah
no screw piece let's shoot it so that's
why I thought of that parallel with that
sort of like that's conspiracy alien
thing which was in for in Starfleet at
the time you couldn't trust anybody and
it was a very much a parallel with what
I thought
um and at the end of that scene
um where they say all that they're still
out there they could come back and of
course they haven't come back but we
noticed on them
they would be a shame I mean I think
they've come back in a couple of the
books okay
um I'd love to see him come back in one
of the like you know the comic strips
the Star Trek are doing at the moment
um some of them are great The Cisco one
is brilliant that there's this God
Killer story and then this is good it
wouldn't work in a TV series or a movie
but in a comment some things don't work
in a TV yeah yeah exactly so yeah yeah
um so I mean so I'd love to see them
returning that and it would like you
said it would end that
that that thread that was just left
hanging there when it
um
all right so we'll get on to
the last bit we were talking about this
is a bit I'm probably most excited about
okay
the fleet is all going to be in one
place yes at the end in the solar system
I've seen some images from the next
um episode and they you can actually see
starbase001 and loads of ships
surrounding it Enterprise f as well
they've got the Enterprise F and they're
decommissioning it I know I mean I
thought we could actually I'd like to
see like a whole episode or something
with it and it's going to be very
briefly seen from what I'll gather a bit
which is a real shame it's just gonna be
a flyby yeah oh man we're going to see
this this vessel that was designed and
by a fan basically and on Star Trek
online and became the Odyssey class it's
a very cool Starship and
we're never going to really see it
um the only thing that I that teases me
with that though a little bit
are we going to see another star a trip
and we're going to see is there a plan
to get another Enterprise in the future
are you being in another series you mean
movie I don't know well if they're
decommissioningly F then surely that was
Jessica going to get a g
and I know I have seen some G designs
actually
um yeah I've seen a couple and there's
an online one where the deflect dish
which has like a line in the middle and
it's really massive it's a beautiful
design I don't know what the class of it
is
um I I don't know I'd like to see a new
Enterprise I'd love to see us I mean I
know it got straight to do Wells but a
contempt well not contemporary but a
25th Century era Enterprise
um would be great to see in a series a
real massive thing and a real sort of
like powerful thing I'd love to see you
yeah a really cool but I just I just
wonder why the commissioner unless
they've got an eye on something why why
bother you know what I mean it's like
why did they write that little Easter
egg in if they're not going to do
something with it
whether it's going to be a comic book or
a game or something it's gonna you know
that they want to do something with it
because it's she's not very old
I think she's about 20 years old though
I'm not sure how long she's been here
you remember the Excelsior class
starship for like a century oh they go
for 100 years
yeah exactly
um she's not particular but they just
said she had so much damage from this
encounter with whatever it was that um
she's it was just she she just need to
be decommissioned but I mean yeah it's
it's a shame and she can't be quite 20
years old because the E went on for
about 10 so she must only be about 10 or
15 years old I didn't have these dates
somewhere once I'll have to Google it
again but um I don't think I don't think
she's 20 years old I think she's about
10 or 10 years old yeah actually you're
thinking about it I think it was a bit
less than 20. I mean do you wish that do
you wish that we had the season uh
rather than being on the title it would
have been the Enterprise f for instance
I thought that's where they were going
to go with it I have to admit when this
started and they were bringing all the
TNG crew back it was announced I was
like well they've got to go for the new
Enterprise haven't they they've got you
and the fans would go crazy but I think
maybe it could have been a bit cheesy
and maybe they are back from that
because also the thing is the whole
point was that the Titan was supposed to
be weaker than the strike it's not it
was not supposed to be able because it's
not a combat ship the new Enterprise
would be the flagship of the Federation
so maybe they just thought it's not
believable a lot of the story you want
to write it wouldn't work yeah they
decided against it but
um I don't know but so
the whole Fleet is going to be in one
place at one time we know the whole plan
the changelings have or whoever is the
Puppet Master is has to happen on this
day so we have to assume that whatever
they're going to do is going to take out
the fleet yeah and that's the point now
again we could talk about how just
nonsensical it makes that the fleet is
in one place at one time
um at the romulans must have just been
like see how many planets we can take
before they come back
makes no sense
um but
that's the only thing that makes sense
all right they must be doing something
to either destroy or capacitate
incapacitate
the entire fleet and we know the fleet's
connected because they mentioned it
didn't they in one of the episodes that
there's this thing there's some sort of
link between each ship so that uh each
ship is traceable so it's almost like a
sort of collective it's like a network
yeah kind of thing so it's not like the
older ships where you know obviously you
could communicate but it's not like
networks now I think that's why let's
just say older ships I think are going
to play
um some kind of uh uh influence in the
last episode from what I understand and
again why would they mention that and
the whole point about how I know there's
the whole point about that the Titan
could be tracked so they had to
sort of deal with that and that's that's
why they couldn't device yeah yeah they
they seem to make that
Point heavily so we'd remember that all
the ships connected and they did
something similar at the end of Prodigy
the cartoon which again if you're a
trekking you've not watched it don't
think about it
no I will watch it after I've seen I
will I will well
check it out we see the end of the
Enterprise E so if you're a trackie and
you want to see how the Enterprise E
ended
um but the thing about The Prodigy was
that um there was this living construct
and it could infect
um any computer system and it made it
basically attack itself so what it is
low to the fleet came in this living
construct started affecting the ships
and the ships started attacking each
other and and that was like obviously
then then it was spreading so I'm
wondering if it's going to be sort of
similar like that that they've got
something that's going to
an effect or the you know using bulk
technology
over you know take over the main control
systems of the fleet
biological and technological aspects so
there could be I don't know if it's the
book it could be some Borg virus which
is communicated through the network of
ship systems and all the ships suddenly
you know they all turn off their life
supports or something or they just crash
into each other I don't know I mean you
know it begs the thought what they could
do with it but if it's involving ships
then that suggests it's going to be
involving as some sort of technological
aspect uh in respect to why the ships
are there and how they can be vulnerable
in destroying members of Starfleet I
assume yeah I think so it just certainly
makes sense to me and then obviously
that that creates an interesting
possibility
that I think it's fair to say we've been
talking about this today and um and I
must have looked like a complete idiot
because I was just grinning at work like
a child
um sort of thing
um
for one you mentioned that obviously you
you think we're going to see the D
yes I do
I'm pretty certain I I'm about 90
certain we're going to see the D
so I mean we know that we think that the
forge is hiding something in the main
Museum of the star-based museum yes yes
and something he hasn't told anybody
about
would that be the Enterprise D or maybe
the sources section has been recovered
with a new Drive section or something
but I think that's what I think is going
to happen that is maybe his pet project
that it's going to be you know that he's
going to get to show his shoes maybe
it's going to be a presentation on on
Frontier today and he was going to be a
big surprise and now he's going to use
it because it's not on this network
system and it's going to be able to be
something he could control and not have
this influence whatever this other thing
is yeah so that does create an
interesting but possibly very cheesy
possibility that the fleet is going to
be disabled um somebody mentioned it in
the in the comments comments a second
ago that very much like Battlestar
Galactica and the you know how oh um
yeah
so the fleet is incapacitated or taken
over by the Borg right at least
electronically
um
a bulk Cube or something else appears
and then obviously with the fleet
incapacitated the ball Cube can just
take him out
so you need a fleet of vessels that are
still operational there's a museum full
of them
just down the road
so could we then see a possibility of a
fleet of the Enterprise d the device was
a yeah
Excelsior Excelsior
um
oh God yeah yeah yeah this Fleet of just
old ships that are going to fly the
classic Voyager yeah
you know this Fleet of classic ships are
gonna fly in and save today sort of
thing and and I know I want I'm torn by
this idea because on one hand I think
this is it's just stupid and if they go
that way I'm gonna be like oh come on
but on the other hand
so happy you everyone would be like I
don't care if it's cheesy this is this
would be so good even if it's a Cheesy
idea you and I and most Starship fans
would just love it I'm sorry
yeah it has it has to be done it really
does it'd be so cool it's it's almost in
a way I've almost got to the point where
anything that happens other than that
idea I'm really really disappointed
um and uh and I hope not because this
series hasn't disappointed to now
very well it's been excellent I don't
see why they would and it's it's like
serratically
oh dude but you never know right I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna have a slight
rant about the job
why not we've got we've got a bit of
time we've got 20 minutes yeah
girati was supposed to be a good Borg
and she turned up with a space vagina
and um which opened up and I never saw
that before but thank you for putting
that idea in my head anyway
um so that turns up right yeah girati
goes aboard the um the star gaze and
attacks yes it's me that would have been
the end of that Series right she's just
gone it's directing done in two minutes
yeah yeah nothing nothing else happened
oh it's just just a thing Chris the D
wasn't destroyed the drive section was
destroyed the saucer section then
crashed what we're saying is did he
recover the saucer section and get a new
Drive section yeah so is it still the
Enterprise D if it's if it's mostly a
different ship I don't know but that's
the half hour half day
um yeah just one D not a double D so
um but yeah so that there's that whole
logical thing about Picard season two
there's a Trattoria just took off a
helmet and gone calmed down guys we're
all right
yeah but the other big problem is the
jatty then like they tried to make out
of the Borg and then sort of good
but she's got a collective of beings
right so she's created tens of thousands
of Borg whatever it would have taken to
build that enormous spaceship Starship
and create a collective unless she has
basically got all of them to volunteer
and they've voluntarily become the Borg
etti's no better than the Borg
she is still enslaved
thousands of beings
but it wasn't very clearly it wasn't
very clear explained because
from what I understand the original book
a lot that were destroyed at the end of
Voyager season seven by the trans Hub
thing but they still existed and this
was a subsect of Borg this girati Borg
yeah
but as you say if for her to do create
that huge ship which was massive
um then surely there would have been a
great ideal of people assimilated in
whatever capacity it is it wasn't very
well explained exactly how it works with
the Girardi book so has it and girati
not a good Queen even though she came
today at the end and I just I'm just uh
it was just so it's just a stupid
episode it generally makes me want to
injure myself
um just to not watch it again if
somebody made me sit and watch it again
I'd be going there are four lights don't
make me watch it um you know I'd give it
immediate
um that's a that's a Star Trek joke
Madrid isn't it yeah the Kardashian
torturous scene I know what you're
talking about
um but but yeah I just I I just always
bugged me and I did it made no sense at
all I do think I'm hoping they do bring
the ball back just to this one because
it would save the day really and it
would save the book The other thing I
was going to say was that um I know that
um
Voyager destroyed the that one uni
Matrix but seven of nine did say that
was only one of five
that all right they were like um
conduits or something weren't they there
was about four in the whole of the
Galaxy and they just destroyed one yes
you're right so they only destroyed one
I think eight four seven two did a lot
of damage to the Borg which is fair so
they were weakened and then that
obviously that that attack avoids it
again weakened them but I just think
they've recovered so fast it was 20
years ago it's a long time ago I mean
they would have been reassimilating
other cultures and stuff like that so
they could always build up their numbers
again since then it's been quite a long
time yeah
um after watching season one I actually
believe I could see Five Lights
yeah
[Music]
I actually almost dreamed of um being
tortured by their friend mother friendly
while I've been watching that crap
um no no but I I honestly think that
season three event of Picard is a saved
Star Trek in so many ways are you
worried though that we might get a cop
out what what if it builds up in the
last two and it doesn't go to the
extremes that we're going to and there's
some ridiculous thing I don't think it
will because what I've understood for
people who have seen the entire thing
they say it's really really good but
there's still a slight worry that they
might do something which is like oh God
did they have to go there you know what
I mean that's you've got to be a bit
realistic haven't you I suppose
yeah I want to say call me when you come
back
I'd love to see him again um if if he's
back I'd love to see him he's you know
because what a good thing if they have
this this thing of the of bringing all
the old ships like the defiant the
Voyager blah blah they've got a crew
them so we could see a bunch of these
ships with crew dotted about from all of
the series
you know Brian we could see I think we
could see we could see all of this crew
return and that again
shiver down my spine then I even thought
about it
I've always said that I've always said
that Harry Kim was gonna be the cats in
the Enterprise F I've been saying that
since the beginning of the season the
beginning of season three
um and I I just like to see Harry Kim
become a Captain after being an Ensign
for seven years so I still hope to see
him I don't see anybody I think he's
better I want to steal him see him as a
Vincent
I got demoted because we saw him he
could be yeah we saw him in a captain in
the last episode of Voyager yeah
California that Tiddly little
spaceship's crap little spaceship
um um so we saw him as a captain I would
just love to see him um like still as an
answer and it's like I can't get
promoted for [__] it's not fair it's
something I just think it would be
interesting I mean you never know I mean
I I think that I I don't know what's
going to happen I mean I know that um uh
I do know some things which are going to
happen I don't know if I'm going to go
on about all of it but
um I think that we're gonna have some
surprises
um but I don't know I mean you hear
things and like with you is some of the
things that you hear sometimes you hear
things and it doesn't always work out so
in the end I'm just as in the blind as
everybody else you know it's not been
properly announced and everything and
they can you know you can't get
disinformation you can get stuff which
actually puts you in the township which
makes you think one thing and it's
completely different so well we know
they've got they do put misinformation
out on purpose nowadays and that is the
amount of stuff I get and I've been
caught out by a couple of times I know I
have and you know I mean me following
Stargate
um I I will hear something and then a
couple of weeks later somebody I speak
to will come and touch me and go yeah
that was that was not true yeah
um and and and they do it on purpose
um because it keeps interesting in
Marvel or the ones that started it
Marvel became Masters at it it's putting
out misinformation
and then they won't go another right and
they've used social media so well
to try and keep and it's to build up
bring up the hype is where they do it
yeah and sometimes they'll even film
entire scenes of stuff they'll film
things slightly different ways
um because they know leaks come from the
set so if there's something really big
they'll film something so they're
spending money to trick us
you know um and and this is something
they've been some of these companies
seems to be really have taken that on
board because I think a few times in
this season we've thought we're going
one way and we've gone another
um you know it seems to be good at it I
mean I was very surprised when the
changes came back I had no idea we're
going to see a regular or not a regular
but a very ominous DS9 threat becoming
the threat for this season as it's from
a different Star Trek series
um really well I thought yeah that's
what I'm saying and I was very very
surprised because I didn't quite believe
it at first and of course then you know
it wasn't only just to change things it
was like a different form of change
things which is why they didn't quite
look like the ones on DS9 it was all
done so well and the thing is though
um is that Terry metallis you know we
said this before but he really does get
Star Trek he's a fan he he he you know
this is why
you know
um
it works so well where some of these I
mean I've been going I'm going to tell
these things too much but some of the
other Star Trek stuff which potentially
might be coming up might not work so
well Terry metallic is season three has
worked it has been made by a Star Trek
fan for Star Trek fans and that is why
it's done so well
yes he definitely adores the thing um I
I think it would be an awful awful shame
if we don't get more track
being run by Taylor
um I say I put a video out actually just
today go and have a look if you haven't
looked I didn't see it I saw it I saw it
very good I I it's one of those videos I
hope it's not true but it's a rumor I
keep hearing over and over again that
actually Alex kurtzman is a little bit
jealous of the success of Picard season
three
yeah because he's gone very quiet ever
since that Picard has become quite
popular in the second half of season
three it's building up momentum and it's
not what he envisioned he's he's just
kind of put his name to it but he's not
been a person who's actually been
involved with creating season three he's
only been so he's just like on the on
the list
um and he wants uh section 31 which I'm
not that bothered about you know
um and I you know but I do Wonder though
because the one hope is that we had
first Contact Day
um April the 5th recently where a lot of
people like me were expecting some big
announcement of a new Star Trek series
especially with all the new Star Wars
series which are coming up there's a lot
of things that happened last weekend do
you think that they didn't say anything
because they could potentially be saving
something up for when Picard season
three wraps and there's some big
announcement
it would would not surprise me if they
announced something as part of the last
two episodes okay I mean they're putting
these last two episodes in IMAX Cinemas
in certain cinemas around America they
have they are very aware that this has
gone well
um you know and trekkies trekkies like
us
um have adored this series so they're
very well yeah
I honestly think they were planning to
announce section 31 on
um on
it's going on my head on April 5th
contact that's what I thought yeah
I think they were planning on doing that
I think it makes no sense that they
announced Starfleet Academy a week
before that and then announced nothing
on April 5th
um if there's a load of memes going
around and you know the thing of when
his date is first comes through the
picture and
um so through the window and he's
looking all angry and um laforge goes
law the meme was
um Paramount's marketing department
because the markets Department it's it's
at Paramount which has been like going
why would we announce it a week before
when we've got that was strange that was
odd a week later and you didn't mention
anything no that was really strange the
rumor I've heard and it is just a rumor
is that they were going to announce
section 31
um with Michelle yeoh and they thought
then Michelle yo tied down and then they
suddenly realized they didn't
okay and she is maybe not going to be
available
so that has caused
all sorts of issues right um
but I've got another video coming up
about that potentially but it doesn't
make any sense but we have got all the
Star Trek birthdays through the year
um you know there is Star Trek diamonds
later in the year and in August time
um there is Federation day
um so you know we do have other
anniversaries as it were to maybe
announce something
um but I'd have thought
it's like it's like having an advert in
the Super Bowl you know you know you
announce something that's what they did
last year to be fair with the TNG didn't
they they did it on the very last sort
of episode yes that's right and then we
saw wolf and the thing come through when
you have that brilliant little end bit
where we're not oh my God we're gonna
get the TNG crew back Jesus Christ I
remember that I was blown away when that
announcement came through it's like oh
my God it was amazing so if they don't
if if nothing gets announced as part of
the last two episodes
I I will be starting to get a little bit
concerned about the future of Star Trek
wow I will I will admit
um because there seems to be something
going on behind the scenes we're not
quite getting the full picture off we
see the smoke but we're not seeing the
fire if that makes sense and and it may
just be that there's the problem is
there are big factions within our fan
base that hate
Alex kurtzman they hate discovery
they hate everything that's been trying
to hate the JJ Abrams Star Treks
I don't like them they hate them
um and I mean properly you know Triple H
sort of thing well really toxic element
of the fan base is what you're saying
yeah going going to an extreme though
but then they take every little piece of
information and everything is Twisted
into well that's Alex Goodson's fault
and and Alex Chrisman is not Satan he
just isn't he he might not be a very
good I I just he just doesn't get Star
Trek person I don't think I mean I don't
I just I just feel that I don't hate him
I I feel that I'd rather have Terry
metallis running in the system rather
than him very much so but in the end
um I've always said this they did listen
to the Commerce of Discovery and um they
decided eventually to do strange new
worlds because we wanted to stand alone
Star Trek Adventure series
um and we got it and it did it really
well and they also they got the card
back which I still um which I'm still
surprised that we actually got so all
right the first two seasons weren't very
good but the third has been you know
singing its Praises of how good it's
good it is we've always been its prices
um do you like to see someone say they
want weyun back because I wanted
weighing back as well we heard that
rumor didn't he that he was going to be
back in the demand
yeah I'm sorry
um I I generally have to check my
passport every so often to make sure I'm
not played by
um Jeffrey Combs I'm sorry am I there
for Coombs everybody so I just have to
check everything
fake your face or something you make
yourself look like Jeffrey Combs you're
not Jeffrey Coombs how are you
well I'm not saying I'll tell you
afterwards okay because it wouldn't
surprise me
um I'm pretty sure Jeffrey Koontz could
walk into this house pretend to be me my
wife would buy it
it's such a brilliant actor
once on Twitter yeah he was really nice
he was going on about his first role he
played this character DS9 who lusted
after Kira and he wanted to holler he
wanted a Holodeck program of Kira and um
I'll come with his character but it was
very funny one he did wasn't it I think
no no it wasn't he wasn't paid he did
play for him yeah he did he played two
he played one on yeah and um brunt as
well yeah
he was brilliant um I I just don't
believe he's not popped up as a
character I just can't believe he came
in is to do something wouldn't you
[Music]
I just I just I just love him I think if
they don't bring him back again that
would be a shame and again you wouldn't
have to pay him anything he'd probably
just turn up give him bloody taxi fare
and like I say the fans would go crazy
um but but yeah that would be awesome
so before we call it in the evening
because it's a work night after all
um actually I'm off this week but yeah
I'm I'm honored today and I volunteered
to do today to be honest I was supposed
to be off today but I volunteered they
were sure volunteered
what was I thinking
um I was thinking that I won a week off
in a couple of weeks that's what I was
going to say for Holiday day but anyway
and so I I'd love to is there anything
that you are really excited about for
the last two episodes and is there
anything that you
are worried about is there any is there
something that if it happened you'd be
like ah [__] or you know
and also drop that on you a little bit
but um okay
um the things I'm excited for are things
we've already mentioned and potentially
because I'm a big ship guy so hopefully
seeing some more classic Starships like
the Enterprise D which I think is likely
um things that disappoint me is if it
was some obscure
uh uh but I think we're gonna see
something that we've seen before so I
think that's kind of like that's not
going to happen but I'm just hoping it's
not something which we are familiar with
in Star Trek but it's a to a less degree
and it's kind of shoehorned in and it
doesn't have a relevance really to uh
the Picard series but I I think that as
it's the end of the Next Generation
properly I think that's unlikely that's
the best one I can explain how about you
what do you think
I did hear a theory that pizza face the
the main villain was actually
species a472
and um and that was just his theory
because he said look we've had a villain
from DS9 we've had a villain from TNG
it's got to be a villain from Voyager
and 8472 is that villain and that was
his theory if they do that I'll be like
that makes no effing sense
but actually species a472 do have would
have a grudge against
um the Federation because it was a
voyager that
you know defeated there was the episode
in Voyager where we saw species 8472 who
had rebuilt Starfleet Academy and they
were making their own sort of practice
uh of actually
um infiltrating Earth and thinking about
it actually there is this is when they
took human form that's where he was
getting his theory from
um as you said that I suddenly collected
the dots that's potential yeah that
would be interesting and we know they
were very Advanced technologically
that's right I would be disappointed if
it's not the Borg at this point if if
they have had so many
hints that it's the Borg I I don't think
it's the Borg necessarily as a whole I
think it's look cute just
right okay I think it's the cutest that
is the threat and that might be just the
being that
was locutus that you know merged with I
think right
and weekly equation has just made that
point
eight four seven two were yeah yeah
telepathy yeah so that might have been
but how that got into Picard's head
I don't know but um and then into his
son said but I I do have a worry that
that they might go that way
um
but if they do it right it still could
be amazing don't get me wrong because
the one thing I did wonder was is it
species not the Borg but using bulk
technology
so is it 8472 using the Borg technology
that's in Picard's head
to take out the Federation but then how
are the change things involved they're
just using the changelings because 8472
cards they're not physically in our
realm oh okay yeah we see yeah okay yeah
um
and and that's where it's coming from
and you know what the more I'm talking
about it now the more I'm thinking that
guy might be a freaking genius and he
might have figured it out
um it could be because there were no
time with the whole of the three static
Series in that era then it will be
something from DS9 something from
Voyager something from TNG it would be
for more free it would be completely
like combination of all three together
yeah oh crap I think you might have
figured it out and I called him an idiot
might you I know that we hear rumors of
stuff I have heard rumors from more than
one source that say that the big uh
villain um in the last two episodes is a
DS9 character villain whatever that is I
can't give you any more because I don't
know
unless it's gold to Cuts who's come back
from the power rates I did see now that
they still they saw that when we saw
Pizza facing I know we saw a slightly
yeah yeah I think they've done that on
purpose I think they very much done that
pizza face to look like lots of
different things
again is Mark Alamo still busy though
the acts are still doing stuff replace
the carts I don't know I don't know but
I mean
um
maybe I I would be disappointed if it
was something like that but actually be
fair I've just taught myself into
believing that if it is eight four seven
two I'd be okay with it actually I've
just put myself into it
um and of course they'd have seven or
nine who knows eight four seven two
she'd be a character who could actually
be involved with explains
and that's why vatic was saying it's
good that it's it's you know it's great
because she's had experience 8472
I think we might have figured it out
we'll find out hopefully very soon we
should be getting the answer tomorrow at
least to who the actual main protagonist
is so um
but anyway as you said it's dropping
tomorrow
um I'm not watching it till Friday
partly because I'm doing a 12 hour shift
tomorrow
um
stupid thing then I've got to get up
early I'm getting up early Friday my
wife's just like why I won't talk for
too long tonight then you need to go to
bed probably so uh but yeah yeah this is
like yeah why are you getting up at six
watch Star Trek are you kidding me
this morning
that you're not talking about so much of
a Star Wars fan but uh Mandalorian
season three episode seven was very good
that's what I'm saying I've heard a
couple of people say it's brilliant I've
heard people say that it's gone from the
worst episode in Mandalorian too one of
the best
I did mine the last one but this one's
very good yeah that's what I'm saying I
didn't hate it I I hated the episode
before that with a big flying thing that
made no sense
with the um it swallowed the kid in this
spot oh the yeah it's fat out and it was
like um holding on to it yeah I remember
that one stupid episode
um but but yeah um I've not enjoyed
Mandalore in the season as much but I
love say to kmk to sack off I would oh
she's great and it will give you a very
small spoiler the latest episode is
starting to have small connections
towards the sequel era you'll see some
interesting things which are starting to
come out that's what I'm saying and I
like what they did that's what I'm
saying they need to stop setting up TV
shows or spin-offs that aren't there now
going to happen though
they've set up a few spin-offs and then
that's how it happens yeah we're not
doing that anymore so anyway but thank
you so much everybody that's joined us
tonight look we've had really great
numbers of people watching live thank
you I love talking about Star Trek
um and we'll we'll talk about it till
the cows command we cannot wait I think
we I think I've been invited onto your
channel yes a couple of weeks time
you'll be on the seller on sci-fi
podcast reviewing season three of Picard
we can't wait to have you it's gonna be
great show yeah I'm gonna come in and
just [__] you can do whatever you like
you're perfectly well good too but very
easy
said the changelings have evolved stupid
I don't think they're going to be
Evolution
that's not Evolution means and then I'm
going to read the dictionary definition
of evolution out to you evolution is
you idiot
um so yeah I'm I'm
gonna yeah I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
be really negative and grumpy all the
way through as if I'm never negative and
grumpy
um
anyway thank you so so much um
it's yeah it's fascinating conversation
we've been geeking it out everybody in
the chat thank you so much for joining
us and um we will see you very soon and
as I said we'll see you over on solo one
podcast in a couple of weeks and
obviously you're going to be back with
us
um at some point when we need me yeah
I'll be back definitely once a month or
so we'll do a live video and we'll get
over and we'll talk about something so
lovely as always
um I'm going to throw up a couple of
quick adverts and then we're out of here
Sidetrack also has some amazing merch
get yours today and show your support at
SCI dashtrack.com
nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to
news stories that we break check out
some of the news articles that we have
already at nineshavrons.com
bye guys
laughs
[Music]
foreign